cashing in on public service and Alabama
Sheriff
is being criticized for finding a way to
line his pockets while keeping one of
his key programs under budget his
defense he does everything by the book
mark Strassmann 24 answers over the past
two weeks me my family my office the
citizens Vettel wall county have been
targets of miscellaneous fake news
stories edible County Sheriff Todd and
Riggins proud of his jail food these
meal trays served to inmates
every day this is a jail this is not a
bed and breakfast if you used to eat and
grandma's Fried Chicken ordering pizza
several times a week you're not going to
be happy
but critics say he is mostly fed himself
over the last three years the sheriff's
food program has run under budget
letting him pocket the leftovers
$750,000 all of it taxpayer money do you
agree that the optics of this are
terrible Dominick's yes but I can't I
can't change octoprint optics more
optics last September and Rickon and his
wife bought this $740,000 beach house
along Alabama's Gulf Coast because a
depression-era state law makes Alabama
sheriff personally responsible for
feeding inmates the performance bonus
and ricchan gave himself is legal I
haven't done anything wrong if they if
it's wrong somebody needs to change the
law want to give it all to charity so
there's no question about it
well this is just like anybody that gets
out here and works every day and it's
the end of the day if you make a profit
it's yours but this is public service
sir public service I have to be the
sheriff and it come with that job and so
I'm not gonna make you happy I promise
you remember taxpayers are footing the
bill here and in Etowah County the
median income is $40,000 a year
the sheriff's bonus is the talk of the
county and the running joke here now is
that everyone wants to be Sheriff
for CBS this morning Saturday mark
Strassmann Gadsden Alabama I'll bet they
all wanted hi Jerry if you blame up I
was just surprised an egg a piece of
toast and grape jelly yeah that's
this is not a this is a jail not a
bed-and-breakfast he said well for that
money he could buy a bed-and-breakfast
that's absolutely right